foreign
[Music]
did you guys bring him up here was he
right here right here awesome
okay and then the the tractor just or
that rolled that way
and that's that's his plow yeah but I'm
just trying to figure this out really
quick was the truck up here where was
the truck so so all right here it is
this thing was all the way up there you
can almost see where he spun around
where the wheels are at where the spin
we went around right there because we
had been we we just finished getting the
truck stuck unstuck out of the snow
so that thing was facing this way right
because he hit me and I was right here
in the truck untied he went up and then
turned around got out to tell me
something
and then that's when it started coming
at me like full pores that's when he
tried to jump back in there right where
right where his blood is at that's right
where it all happened okay he slipped
because these tracks there's no way that
there's no way to stand on him foreign
facing which direction
okay and then I get in I immediately
start like like reverse and slipping and
slipping I'm already getting hit and
then that's when it's
just trying to send it back because
straight at me yeah this is his cousin
that truck was stuck in the driveway
they were using this to get the truck
out of the driveway so he pulled it up
right they got the truck unstuck right
here truck is facing
westbound
um
he gets out well he's in the truck sales
facing this way on the street where
those tracks are he turns that thing
around gets out of this snow thing
gets out to talk to him this thing's
still in drive he tries to jump on the
track to jump back in it to stop it
so he rolls off the front of the track
and gets run over by it